hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at a cool opening the
Latvian gambit what starts out with pani
for pani 5 Knight to f3 development move
and pawn to f5 and as you can already
see here without this f5 pawn move this
is a very common opening that you'll see
from white but a lot of times as you can
imagine they're not studied up on this
move right here a player starting out
with E 4 and Knight to f3 is really not
expecting black to play this live being
gambit and a lot of times they may not
have seen it at all and so if you're not
playing at a master level if you're
playing club level or below rated 1800
or below I would definitely recommend
looking at this because you're going to
see this opening a lot from white and so
if you get very good at the Latvian game
it and you're a very aggressive player
this is not a very good opening if
you're not a aggressive player at all
but if you are very aggressive and you
want to learn a new line I definitely
recommend this because Black has a lot
of success especially if White's never
seen this a lot of times they can have a
very easy win because watch is not
accustomed to playing against this
defense from black so we're going to
take a look at some of the main lines
from both sides and talk about some of
the key concepts that you always want to
remember when playing the Latvian gambit
the main line continues with Knight
takes on e5 and Black has three options
here and we're going to take a look at
each of those the first one the main
line is Queen to f6 I don't really play
this a lot but it is the main line so I
want to talk about it and white has two
options here he can bring down his pawn
to d4 to hold on to this Knight or
instead since he's going to kick his
Knight out anyway if we move our pawn up
a lot of times you'll see why bring is
Knight back to c4 here and that's the
main line what you also may see from
black is bringing his knight to c6 and a
lot of times from here one of the common
themes you'll see in the lab in game it
is white bringing his coin
beam down to h5 from here blacks forced
to bring his pawn to g6 now from here
white has two options he can take our
knight on c6 attacking our queen from
here it's actually recommended that you
take with your pawn on d7 to c6 instead
of taking the queen right away
the Queen's now going to be forced to
move but instead this is just a better
setup if we take instead if we take this
Queen and now he takes our queen it's
just a better setup for us so that's one
option that white has but another option
that you'll see a lot is if white takes
on g6 and he can do this because if we
take back on g6 he can come down and
take our rook now that's not to say that
we don't want to do this again a lot of
times if you play the Latvian gambit
you're all about sacrificing pieces over
and over and over again so a lot of
times you'll see players for black
either capture and just give up this
rook and at the same time try to
completely get the White Queen out of
the game and then start to attack or
instead if they don't take here you may
see the knight come to f6 holding down
this pawn on h7 at the same time
attacking this Queen on h5 so if the
knight moves for a discovered check then
we can now take this Queen so this Queen
for white is going to have to move now
so this is why a lot of times more times
than not you'll see Knight to f6 so this
is one of the options with Knight to c6
from white excuse me from black another
option that we do have is Bishop to
see five and this is another gambit
itself we're basically looking to bait
white into taking an extra pawn on f5
black is going to have a tough time
actually playing the game if white
decides to bring his queen down and
after we bring on our pawn to g6 kind of
as we talked about if he takes we can
bring our knight to f6 and then he can
move away he's going to move his queen
away but this is going to be a tough
game for black still playable but a
tough game for black what we're hoping
to do if we do play this is a lot of
times you'll see white take this extra
extra pawn on f5 and this is really what
we're going for and we're going to
actually sacrifice another piece by
bringing our Bishop down to f2 and from
here White's going to recapture with his
King and then we're going to bring our
Queen to h4 checking this as you can see
blacks giving up material in hopes that
he can get the White King out in the
middle and then start to attack and
hopefully get a checkmate pretty soon
now from here white has limited number
moves if he tries to retreat let's say
to g1 then black can come in and retake
this knight on e5 after check this King
now if white tries to just come back to
e2 again we can do the same thing check
the king and attack this Knight the best
move for white is to bring his King to
f3 and now from here black has three
options and you can play around with
what you think is best but the three
options really that you have are
bringing your knight to f6 and this is
good because these two squares on g4 and
E 4 are really huge attacks for black if
we kick this Knight away for white
that's on e5 with a simple move pawn to
d6 or something else even bringing our
knight in c2 action then these two
squares become huge we have our queen
and our knight attacking these squares
we can get both of them involved those
are going to be very deadly and why it's
going to have to do something
to defend those the second move that you
may see if you're playing black is
Knight to e7 and this is done so that he
can and turn his next move if he wants
to is take this pawn on f5 and this is
going to give his knight a really active
square where he had some very deadly
checks he can then come to d4 as a nice
check if he moves his Queen he can come
to h4 so a lot of players would like to
play their Knight to e7 so that they can
capture this pawn and also they would
like to castle on the Kings side and
have this rook on the F file bearing
down without the knight in the way if
the knight is played to f6 then he's
going to be in the way but if he's
played the e7 like we're looking at
right now then after we castle on the
Kings side this rooks going to have the
F file to bear down on then the last
minute that you will see is pawn to b5
and this does two things one it starts
to attack on the Queen side as you can
see we've already started to obliterate
the King side that starts to attack the
Queen's up at the same time the next
move from black is we'd like to bring
our bishop to b7 and this is going to
attack white check in and also get
another piece involved at the same time
gain a tempo for black so these are your
three options all three of them as you
can tell are very aggressive from black
and this all stems from hoping that
white earlier on took the extra pawn on
f5 again if he doesn't and he brings his
Queen down immediately it's going to be
a little harder it's still going to be a
very aggressive game from black and play
but it is going to be a little harder so
let's go and take a look at another line
that you may see if you do play the lab
being another variation you'll see a lot
is Bishop to c4 from here we're just
going to take this pawn on e4 the
Knights going to be forced to move
capturing on e5 and we're going to
develop our Knight to f6 defending our
pawn and we're going to go ahead and
give up this move to Knight to f7 and
from here our Queens going to come to e7
this is very important and we'll see
that just a minute we're going to give
up this rook
again the labbing gambit feel free
to give up as much materials you need to
after it does this we can now bring our
pawn to d5 and the bishop now has to
come back to e2 if he doesn't come back
to e2 he goes back to let's say b3 then
we can bring our Bishop to g4 and we're
going to win this Queen one way or
another again this Queen on e7 is very
important because it eyes down and if
our pawn moves
we now have a discovered attack on the
White Queen on the excuse me on the
White King so this is one variation that
you'll see more times than not let's go
and take a look at a few more the next
move you might see from white is Knight
it's a c3 simple development move
attacking the center and getting another
minor piece involved and from here
blacks going to play similar to the
Kings gambit on the reverse side and
he's going to bring his knight to f6
attacking this pawn here on e4 at the
same time he's going to look to get his
Bishop his dark squared Bishop involved
and then castle on the Kings side and
have his rook on this F fob bearing down
so if you're familiar with the Kings
gambit a lot of times if you see this
variation from white it's going to be a
lot like the King's gambit just played
on the flipside as you're playing from
black so you may see this it's very rare
that you will see this but you may see
it and the last one that you may see
instead of taking with his Knight to e5
you may see the pawn capturing on f5 and
this is completely fine blacks going to
continue to push up the board with pawn
to e4 attacking this Knight and then you
may see the knight come down to e5 and
then black has a few options but the
most common move that you'll see from
black here is bringing his knight to f6
cone as we talked about the before now
instead of attacking he's defending this
pawn on e4 getting ready to get his dark
squared bishop involved at the same time
he can castle on the Kings side so as
you can see this is going to be a very
aggressive line from black as he
is down this F file and these are the
most common lines that you will see the
lab being game obviously the first
couple that we looked at are going to be
the ones that you see more often than
not but there are a few times where if
someone completely hasn't seen it you
may see them play one of these last few
moves but as you can tell from this
opening it's a very aggressive opening
and black has a lot of good lines that
he can completely destroy white so if
you're playing with someone that hasn't
seen this or you're playing someone much
higher rated that is completely well
versed in the Italian game and the Rye
Lopez and a lot of the games that stem
from this Knight to f3 in the very
beginning you may just want to throw
this in there and just see how they
react to it because a lot of times white
has an epic fail and just gets destroyed
by black so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video hopefully you guys have
learned something new about a new
opening that you may have never seen
before if you haven't already please
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching